I don't understand what is preventing
you from laughing this off and giving me
a big hug you're not forgiven
Michael
be liked absolutely not I like to be
liked I enjoy being liked
I have to be liked
but it's not like this
compulsive need
be liked like my need to be praised
I'm sorry I'm so sorry you lied to us
yeah I lied to myself too
I'm not a millionaire
I thought I would be by the time I was
30 but I wasn't even close and then I
thought maybe by the time I was 40
but
by 40 I had less money than when I was
30 Maybe by my 50s I don't know
okay
the city
Dwayne
we're not mad we are just disappointed
no we are man yes we are we are livid
but we are going to let this one slide
thank you we're not I am not a mind
reader David
[Music]
um
look this is a very serious offense we
have cause to fire you can you shut down
instead
shut down please instead what I think we
should do is strip you of your title of
safety officer and we should take a part
of his pay and donate it to the charity
of your choice something that Dwight
doesn't like Peter Michael you have to
take responsibility here one of your
employees had a heart attack he could
have died because of the way you're
allowing your office to run do you want
that on your conscience do you
Michael you're talking to me yeah
what
I thought Nano raised some good
questions
what kind of a name is nano
it means grandmother
look I'm sorry to do this but can you
drop me back at the telemarketing
building you know Michael you want to
succeed huh you've got to apply the same
thank you
Aaron do we have any of those clips that
hold paper together Staples
David Wallace called oh he did what did
he say he heard you made a big splash at
the meeting oh my God that was so mean
what I just said and I didn't mean it
was Kevin and Meredith put me up to it
Michael don't listen to them thank you
Stanley you just ignored their carpig
okay Michael yes a carp is both a fish
and a term for complaining they're
mocking you with work play hey boss did
you find Nemo I could name Pixar movies
too Toy Story don't you mean koi story
I think that pretty much sums it up
I found it at Spencer Gifts
you know what
we're not that different you and I when
I clamped my foot into a non-stick you
know what Michael yeah
let me stop you right there okay and
leave did you see born on the 4th of
July
I was under the impression that Billy
would be more like that guy
Pam
when Carol said no tonight
I think I finally realized how you must
be feeling
we are both the victims of broken
engagements
yeah you were never really engaged I was
in that
marriage Arena though
yeah yeah
well I kind of thought something would
happen tonight too
so like
so I like
what are you doing what are you doing
I'm objecting her yes I didn't
and I have a ride home
you sit in the back I am actually your
boss Michael Scott welcome wow you are
very exotic looking was your dad a GI or
all right since I am the boss I will
drive as well who wants shotgun you
can't be serious you ran a woman over
this morning everyone inside the car was
fined Stanley
guess what I have flaws what are they
oh I don't know I sing in the shower
sometimes I spend too much time
volunteering
occasionally I'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue me no don't sue me that's the
opposite of the point that I'm trying to
make
okay I want you to be Daryl and ask me
for a raise because I need to try out
some of these negotiation tactics on you
where'd you get that Wikipedia Wikipedia
is the best thing ever
anyone in the world can write anything
they want about any subject so you know
you are getting the best possible
information solution is honesty laughter
and comedy in short vacation what no no
I am talking about a roast
of Michael Scott
oh come on who here has a Comedy Central
roast Channel you've seen it right
everybody gets together and you start
hurling insults at the one guy and
everybody's laughing and everybody is
hugging each other can I call you
serious you really want us to roast you
yeah it's easy and you are that's
offensive it's not it's not offensive
during a roast anything goes and I want
you guys to really get cracking on this
I want you to take me down don't hold
back I want you to really make fun of
anything about me it could be My Race
could be the fact that I'm so fit or I'm
a womanizer fair game whatever I don't
want to write your stuff for you but I
just want it to be good
you know sometimes
to get perspective
I like to think about a space man on a
star incredibly far away
and our problems don't matter to him
because we're just a distant point of
light
but you feel sorry for me
because he has an incredibly powerful
microscope and you can see my face
I'm okay
no I'm not
look at that look at that
hello okay
that's great that is good
foreign